alle zwei wochen takt sylvia werner ihr
licht fällt auch fürs fotoshooting ihrer
taschen die die aus recycelten
materialien die bilder stellt sie dann
ins netz
die kunden fragen das auch ab so haben
sie im internetauftritt haben wir auch
einen eigenen shop den eigenen job haben
wir eigentlich nur gemacht weil die
kunden danach gefragt haben die
modedesignerin aber möchte mehr als
anonym im netz verkaufen wie ist
mitglied bei online city wuppertal eine
plattform nur für wuppertaler händler
auf haushaltswaren händler feuerstein
ist dabei er muss kämpfen um kunden
nicht an die online riesen zu verlieren
ein eigener online-shop ist ihm zu teuer
aber 60 euro monatlich für den
wuppertaler marktplatz findet er gut
ich glaube einfach dass dieser ansatz
einer lokalen plattform aus der
vielleicht mal eine gesamtstädtische
community entstehen könnte
genau der richtige ist um gerade dem dem
inhabergeführten ortsansässigen
einzelhandel eine ebene zu geben auf der
er erfolgreich auf sich innerhalb der
stadt darstellen kann
in der eigenen stadt einkaufen ohne bei
regen vor die tür müssen
inzwischen bieten rund 60 wuppertaler
händler ihre waren auf dem internet
marktplatz an und versuchen dem
gesichtslosen onlinehandel paroli kunden
darum das zu schaffen was der reine
online händlern nicht ganz durch eine
verbindung zu schaffen zwischen den
stationären handel wo immer noch
beratung wo immer unsere vögel und also
das gespräch stattfindet
geliefert wird noch am selben tag gegen
ein paar euro nach hause
oder aber die kunden holen die ware im
schauen der online klick die ableitung
hier können die beteiligten händler auch
noch ein ladenregal als
ausstellungsfläche mieten sowie
feuerstein
insgesamt sind die umsätze über den
marktplatz noch sehr bescheiden aber die
wuppertaler einzelhändler wollen
weitermachen und gegen das ladensterben
ihrer stadt kämpfen auch wenn sylvia
werner ihre taschen nach wie vor vor
allem auf märkten und im laden überkauft
und ich denke das ist die einzige
möglichkeit ist unsere innenstädte auf
der lebendiger zu gestalten so ein dass
ihnen ein buch früher hatte man buch in
der hand und guckte so ich brauche
klempner ich brauche das ich brauche das
heute ist es so dass wir das online
anbieten können
auch wenn die händler geduld und langen
atem brauchen wuppertal hat ein zeichen
gesetzt
eine handvoll anderer städte in
deutschland sind bereits nachgezogen und
bauen sich ebenfalls die einkaufsstraßen
im world wide web